[Music]
welcome back to another godforsaken
video of the careful boys well we have
Jared and Dr
[Applause]
Michael today contrary to the last one
what do you get the most compliments
about oh oh like it could be physical it
could be anything personality based
characteristic it could it could even be
a lie right be a
lie people say to me that you have a
nice t-shirt
on no one's ever complimented me you
know what's crazy I'm so [__] Asian
the minute I hear the start of a
compliment my ears just shut off like I
don't deserve it I think they're lying
huh I think they're lying trying to make
you feel better yeah and I'm like shut
the [__] up I feel like a piece of [__]
inside my own head don't you [__]
[__] with that reality don't you [__]
with that
real keeps me hungry I get more do
something I don't know gratitude from
fans then I get compliments so like
lately I've been running into fans
that's watched us when they were kids
cuz this is like our 16th year now Dam
you guys are like an institution I'm one
of those yeah so then they would be
like they're like [__] I remember and
then I would get a lot of thank you for
being a part of my childhood you made it
crazy and I remember I had so many great
memories watching your videos and me and
my friends playing and acting it out and
all that stuff my Airbnb host really who
happens to be a cherry uh she's a JK fan
no way she saw she saw you on JK news
she saw you on JK news and you led with
that I said I better see you in the
comments that's tight that's smooth
that's
good ma chees moo cheeso I don't know if
that's a compliment but I do feel like
it's something around the same vicinity
of a compliment I don't know yeah
there's people I meet that like I
watched it when I was 8 and I'm 24 now
and I'm like shut up don't remind me how
old I'm I got I got a complo I finally
got yeah finally what [__] are you
about to
say I don't want to hear about no no
construction tools I don't want to hear
about
it for the record Jared is my literal
biological that's the only compliment
you ever get your son is [__] great
man the best compliment I ever heard God
damn your son can throw a [__]
football that's
right um no I was uh uh told on many
occasions and it it at first it felt
good and then later hearing this felt
great um if you say some [__] about
cingus I'm G punch you in the face cuz
you're full of [__] keep going it was
very
close advertis Mike the ladies would
start oh my [__] Mike oh my God you
it's not the smallest I've ever seen the
most at
Apex tip top of the mountain you know
what I'm saying when the clouds like
this and you're like cuz you're more tip
with the spear like they send steel Team
Six type of [__] you give me the most
below average mediocre sex I have ever
had and I'm talking about you want to
feel good about the [__] you're like all
right L you did
no you didn't that was that was and it
wasn't a the best of the be you can't
even cuz like you're a [__] that gets
laid you're going to tell your
girlfriends at brunch that's what brunch
is for telling the other
ho some that's the worst part you're
going to tell your your [__] about
like yo this [__] plowed me
under he had snake tongue did some Demon
[__] your girl was up doing this [__]
that you can say then you could say yo
small wrinkled dick [__] [__]
little [__] he sucked he begged for for
I denied him I kicked him out that's
funny how do you explain when they're
like how was it she's just
like all right like it's clear that I'm
trying but just not much is happening
but something happening so she I get her
on that that where she's like oo okay
but then I'm like that that's all I got
and she's
like the plan's Landing back down to oh
it's like you you just can't wait to get
to Vegas with your friends and they're
like route to Montana or something
you're like that's a fine place no it's
like a flight from Dallas to San Antonio
30 minutes in air why are you even
taking get water instead of soda you
could [__] here's I promise you and I'm
a married man but back in my single days
I could promise you this you could
either go home with me or you could go
and watch half a Netflix episode of some
[__] and have just the same kind of
time it's that it's that your favorite
show it's a good show what was the plot
I don't really remember I was on my
phone the whole time but your boy's
there 247 it's reliable
you want some reliable reliable that's
the real compliment here reliable the
not so yes it's like a episode of turn
your brain off yeah it's like a court
show it's like a episode of Storage Wars
you just have it playing comforting
that's how [__] describe me he's in
the background doing some [__]
reliably like trustworthy Kelsey is like
hey Kelsey what' you do like oh my God I
[__] like four black dud was incredible
oh
Kelsey you know J what did you do she
like well like I had like three Asian
guys go down on the in like oh my God
they're so G at right Becky what did you
do and you can't say like I just sat at
home and watched half an episode of
Netflix you got to try to get your
[__] to understand you're a [__]
that [__]
too so you recount the story when you
were with me when you were like yeah
um and that and that and then she said
enough and that's it and they know too
they're like Mike she's
like he was nice
yeah he was nice we tried we tried he
tried wow that's the greatest compliment
you get best in the world of that
[__] try having some more
mediocre the best below average mediocre
apex apex apex of the best yeah it's a
participation award but there I mean
there's ltimate form timate form yeah
absolutely I really participated yeah
you did and I got something for it
because if you participate like a
[__] yeah and you get nothing
out of it it's kind of inspirational cuz
damn you're still trying and if you win
the whole [__] then you're famous your
reward was shrugs at brunch that's it
that's it my reward was honorable
mention at brunch y shugs not even a
punchline off that [__] like all the
crazy one that has sex with all black
dudes and all the Asian foresome and
then with Mike just like she says it and
they're like so yeah they changed the
subject this place is fun for ladies
where's our food yeah food's cold you
you seen the waiter I did that [__] all
[__]
day top that [__]
[__] we got
Apex it's just not fair it's a fronted
video better than mediocre sex easily
tops it but but in spirit anthon should
go next I get compliments yeah dude you
get compliments all the time just
[__] beautiful I me you had me and
him in one episode he does [__] you dude
some of us weren't born Wen born perfect
yeah you know what I don't get that as
often as I would like that's very nice
that that is maybe it's because I'm also
hanging around a bunch of
Jerry's that some accusatory yeah but
that's that's the number one compliment
that I'll receive which is like
something I'm not in control of you know
Jer that I'm tall but I'm not even like
tall I'm just tall for Asians aren't you
6 foot you are tall though 512 baby yes
I am 512 is 6 foot man thank you Jo you
tall dude are you a
mathematician that's that's just the
first thing and you know what don't be
six I get it most from aune don't be six
foot and say I'm not Paul Auntie don't
is 6 feet just tall like no matter what
you got to call him and say thank you
later anyway cuz your mom makes you yeah
damn damn dude I grew up in like Russian
Jewish culture it's the same [__]
[__] yeah all that old world shit's the
same then are buddy he's a Ukrainian Jew
and I was just like you know what you
guys are like Asians but you use reason
and logic that's the only difference
[__] logic but no emotions though best I
got is can you go make sure your aunt I
didn't overdose
again white trash champion of the world
baby she's on the floor some [__] coming
out of mou I don't know oh you're turn
Jared got big
Cals those are hard to grow sh
I showed him last time you can see it he
does that big [__] it is big man holy
[__] in that thing that [__] look like a
big old turkey leg right there white
trash if I I we're stuck in the
mountains we're trying to eat you first
but I don't know if we can bite through
it you could yeah maybe are you part Ox
yes that's good why you got a [__]
Asian recipe
to look like oxtail I'm not part
dog I'm not part dog Chinese recipe
yeah Nails it again dude yo earlier I
didn't want to say anything now that
we're
boys yeah yeah yeah yeah no joke when I
first walked in here there's apparently
in this neighborhood a little dog
someone owns and he runs around he'll
just run in here he came in here and he
came in here I was like you a dumb
[__]
dog damn you're you walked in the wrong
office come on dog he's tiny he's
wagging his Tails I can't I can't bear
with was looking at that dog and we were
licking our lips dude about to be some
fried rice you I was going side eye on
that dog you name it he was about to be
in it I'm hungry that always coming in
here looking little dog he looks
scrumptious cuz e all the trash of the
complex yeah we've been feeding them
just stuff them
up
long delayed gratification that's what
we're about here soup is the bomb though
just throwing that out there said what
oxel soup is the bomb I thought you said
something El hey would you hear baby I
thought you going to say dog is pretty
good that's what do they dog they fre
really dog somewhere I didn't mean to
look at you guys you're cool yeah yeah
they would never guess it there's a dog
Festival that they eat them at what
Amica sad China that's sad people in
China are trying to get it shut
down cuz China cool China's great Pro
China all right we don't want to get
canceled for
real so you got big [__] C that's the
the number one compl that can't be it
dude that can't be it are most of the
compliments you get about your body and
do you feel objectified sexualized I
mean I think most compliments everybody
gets is about their body on average I've
never got a [__] compliment about my
body [__] oh look how hairy you are
that's not a [__] compliment did you
put your head in the head Shin ball you
get that one I get people think I have
like horns from no my shit's not yeah
whatever the [__] that is like OB I get
insulted more than I get if we're
Counting YouTube comments the hair come
on oh yeah well that's not they're just
they hate people hate the hair oh
absolutely I really it's only there hair
because you guys hate it so but
honestly YouTube people there's a
specific type of person that really gets
triggered by Jared's hair and it's
something we call an involuntary
celibat I know you're thinking about
Jared's [__] Mohawk dud you are zero
for zero on [__] [__] and while
meanwhile Jerry's Mohawk only folds like
that because it's soft deep in Latina
and Filipina juices holding it together
it's a landing strip it is a target I
had [__] 10 years too long wa too long
10 should we shave it what was the
inspiration of the Mohawk
dangle it wasn't Mohawk it looks like a
mohawk that that just I called the I
call it Flash and Mohawk it is you know
dick jokes all instead of it like erect
it's like relaxed 100% there was a
mohawk and then it just grew a little
bit too long and I was like I'm [__]
lazy I'm just going to that's cool you
know if you just shave it off then you
don't have to do anything do you care
about how the rest of you looks minus
your body AB you take care of your face
and hair and teeth I wasn't going to say
anything about tee I know a popular
German character where if you move that
just a little bit this way and go all
the way that it kind of matches so like
a full head of hair Hitler kind of it
goes this way I mean you're a lot closer
to the Uber MCH than Hitler ever [__]
was here was like where a perfect people
[__] you're five five and look
like
[__] is there a point at the end of the
spot where you kill yourself and let us
all be perfect
together that's weird no one ever talked
about that
[__] what I'm trying to say Jerry is you
the real Hitler in a good
way in a good
way that's actually what it is yeah it's
just
transplant moved it up do women ever
compliment you on your
face [__] hair looks my looks yeah
what do they say they like about you I'm
like they're [__] lying you kind of
got cute eyes shut up and I get that
hey nice got cute eyes I'm always like
you're [__] full of [__] I can't tell
if other men are how goodlooking they
are same give me 10 yeah 10 10 women 100
women I'll line them up as to my
preference hottest to least hot no
problem it's algorithm just happens
automatically it's [__] just that's
it they it'll line themselves but with
dudes the ugliest [__] I'm like
I feel like it's that guy it's usually
correct and the best goddamn looking
[__] ever I'm like yeah there's
something to it every one of those eight
guys or 89 guys or whatever in between
I'm like could be this way could be that
way so I asked like my wife like hey is
that guy good looking she's like no and
I'm like what there's no Rhyme or Reason
figure this out when I saw you I was
like yeah yeah yeah straight beautiful
I'm straight stra I'm straight say if I
he's the most attractive man on the
podcast comment comment and agree please
that's why he's the he's the sex don't
put me in this position abely somehow
the fans are going to turn it [__]
sideways all over you're just lucky
Steve's not here this is not going to be
politically correct okay we already
talked about us e dog so it's okay look
how put together he is yeah you call
them the right Hitler the correct is it
correct for me to
assume this is going to sound so
perverse and so wrong oh great here we
go even better here we go I don't know
if you guys know this this may be news
to you Fells FS the typical what I
imagine to be a female jking news lover
is like the Pinnacle of what all white
men like slob Orcs try to climb the
mountain to a cheat but just some Dime
Piece Japanese racer girl [__] who does
the Midnight Club you know like one of
those [__] with the race like you
know you know what I'm saying
you clearly must just like bomb through
fields of that [__] that's what I'm
saying dude that's what I've been trying
to say like I've been my whole life was
a sex yeah my my wife my wife is a
[__] gorgeous little [__] thick
ass Filipina [__] I love it but that's
my barely just try my [__] out phds
and make a shitload of money and be all
Innovative and [__] just to get my one
and I got it like never let go you're
like living free in the [__] world
and just batting them off like excuse me
ma'am please take your perfect body way
my man's chilling right now he can't
he's in overdose mode for me that's why
he back Filipina himself how I did and
uh my sometimes my mother-in-law watches
this but
uh back in the
day back in the day but only with your
daughter only the only one yeah only
never had any show them the tat dude
show to oh yeah just just do the song
now it's now it's almost regretted
that's for Nick almost it's for Nick for
me it's for Nick for Nick he's straight
though he's straight I'm also straight
yeah hey I appreciate that's probably
the best compliment I've ever had in my
life you go hey we say the same exact
thing and you get this sex is just not
as poetic it's not we not poetic people
dude you think you think can put that
together that guy has a PHD I'm not
smart like that I can't even say a
sentence without stuttering dude vomited
poetry in ways that I never knew existed
this guy shakespear me with math he's a
doctor dude he's PhD I need him on more
often speak with crayons he speaks with
[__]
oil PS that you
got I get bored dude he's using quill
and cursive feather tip pin can I be
wearing one of them 1880s outfits and
[__] like that like Shakespeare but the
crazy thing is he brings it down here
first he's like I don't want to be
politically incorrect so you know your
foundation's like what is he going to
say I like the modern look with the
quill I think yeah hot that's like some
50 Shades of Gray
type
oh your turn clean the best compliment
absolutely we still got I feel like you
always get you got you got super fans
that compliment you all the time here
what do they say oh wow that you're
their favorite uh favorite's not
necessarily the word they use what do
they say I think they say things like
hot fine
beautiful that's what they do probably
the best compliment was like you're not
what I
expected huh that's kind of like Mike's
uh Chinese yeah his sex they're talking
about my Chinese part of you real part
Chinese yes I can kind of tell yeah it's
the cheeks mhm it's the cheeks still I'm
never going to believe you I'm sorry you
don't have to be cuz I will be Chinese
whether you believe me or not I don't
know if I'd make claims like that you
see if you register on the J radar you
might not actually be any part oh
yeah there's 23 in
Jerry
you can't pass the test be born in Asia
I'm only sensing Jerry force in this re
little bit right here yeah yeah yeah
yeah little up on that side of the room
that's the Asian table we can't tell the
people we can't tell the people that
that I am now 34% Chinese is it growing
yeah the the stats change depending on
like the world's not so black and white
you know yeah it's not so white and
Chinese yellow
it's only black and white when you
yingyang yeah but the black and white
has more black and white inside you
don't want to make this too racial black
and White's toxic no I'm fully white
you're right are you pure Caucasian I'm
pure all things European
[Laughter]
yeah did you do a 23 me I did wait how
can you be a third of some [__] what the
[__] you have three parents I never said
that three but I thought the [__]
was holy [__] I never thought of it that
way two things in quarters and eights
drugs you buy in San Francisco people
buy the bridge and ethnicity and
ethnicity would it would it work if one
like one parent is so like your
grandparent is full and then the other
parent is a quarter and then so you can
have 33% he's just being an
idiot I've been familiarized with it um
but like all totally all jokes aside
like zero humor yeah cuz I can't tell
you're for real a third I'm for real not
a
third 34% yeah yeah 33.33 it actually
just went down I think let me check down
to Z now oh it's went through me updates
every from it's 1% indous it's true
33.33 333 that's exactly it says right
here
34 34.3 now fascinating I think it's the
room it boosts up your Chinese depends
on who's guesting and who's who's
squinty enough so you went up a little
bit yep I guess so been wither you guys
let him say this about your people what
the [__] man what you talking about I'm
just talking about my eyes we're boys
now right
[Music]
right
for